[Music]
the single most powerful asset we have
is our mind
if it is trained well it can create
enormous wealth in what seems to be an
instant
[Music]
find the game where you can win
and then commit your life to playing it
and play to win
[Music]
successful people ask questions they
seek new teachers they're always
learning
the problem with having a job is that it
gets in the way of getting rich
[Music]
small and dream big
if you want to be financially free
you need to become a different person
than the one you are today
and let go of whatever has held you back
in the past
the philosophy of the rich and the poor
is this
the rich invest their money and spend
what is left
the poor spend their money and invest
what is left
sight is what you see with your eyes
vision is what you see with your mind
never say you cannot afford something
that is a poor man's attitude
ask how you can afford it
your future is created by what you do
today not tomorrow
the more i risk being rejected
the better my chances are of being
accepted
one of the most stupid things to do is
to pretend you are smart
when you pretend to be smart
you are at the height of stupidity
find out where you are
where you want to be
and build a plan to get there
[Music]
most people want everyone else in the
world to change let me tell you it's
easier to change yourself than to change
everyone else
people who dream small dreams continue
to live as small people
the richest people in the world build
networks everyone else is trained to
look for work
there are those who make things happen
there are those who watch things happen
and there are those who say what
happened
skills not theories make you rich
losers quit when they fail
winners fail until they succeed
when you come to the boundaries of what
you know
it is time to make some mistakes
the ability to sell is the number one
skill in business
if you cannot sell don't bother thinking
about becoming a business owner
most people are too lazy to think
instead of learning something new
they think the same thought day after
day
education is cheap
experience is expensive
there are no mistakes in life just
learning opportunities
the love of money is not the root of all
evil the lack of money is the root of
all evil
when you are forced to think you expand
your mental capacity when you expand
your mental capacity your wealth
increases
[Music]
making mistakes isn't enough to become
great
you must also admit the mistake and then
learn how to turn the mistake into an
advantage
in today's rapidly changing world the
people who are not taking risks are the
real risk takers
excuses are a dime a dozen
that's why the poor have so many of them
people need to wake up and realize that
life doesn't wait for you if you want
something get up and go after it
if you want to be rich serve more people
it is easy to stay the same
it is not easy to change
most people choose to stay the same all
their lives
[Music]
it does not take money to make money
[Music]
a mistake is a signal that it is time to
learn something new
something you didn't know before
[Music]
there are no bad business and investment
opportunities but there are bad
entrepreneurs and investors
if you want to go somewhere it is best
to find someone who has already been
there
success is a poor teacher we learn the
most about ourselves when we fail
so don't be afraid of failing
failing is part of the process of
success
you cannot have success without failure
the wealthy by luxuries last while the
poor and middle class tend to buy
luxuries first why
emotional discipline or lack of it
when times are bad is when the real
entrepreneurs emerge
sometimes you win
sometimes you learn
you get one life live it in a way that
inspires someone
when i started my last business i didn't
receive a paycheck for 13 months
the average person can't handle that
pressure
[Music]
getting rich begins with the right
mindset the right words and the right
plan
[Music]
sometimes what is right for you at the
beginning of your life
is not right for you at the end of your
life
business is like a wheelbarrow nothing
happens until you start pushing
business and investing are team sports
the hardest part of change is going
through the unknown
financial struggle is often the direct
result of people working all their lives
for someone else
being an entrepreneur is simply going
from one mistake to the next
you must have the fortitude to continue
[Music]
the most life-destroying word of all is
this
tomorrow
intelligence solves problems and
produces money
money without financial intelligence is
money soon gone
[Music]
the size of your success is measured by
the strength of your desire
the size of your dream
and how you handle disappointment along
the way
[Music]
the most successful people are mavericks
who aren't afraid to ask why
especially when everyone thinks it's
obvious
hoping drains your energy
action creates energy
[Music]
the more a person seeks security the
more that person gives up control over
his life
[Music]
everyone can tell you the risk
an entrepreneur can see the reward
the only difference between a rich
person and a poor person is how they use
their time
[Music]
your choices decide your fate
take the time to make the right ones
if you make a mistake that's fine
learn from it and don't make it again
money is really just an idea
talk is cheap
learn to listen with your eyes actions
do speak louder than words
watch what a person does more than what
he says
the moment you make passive income and
portfolio income a part of your life
your life will change
those words will become flesh
if you realize that you're the problem
then you can change yourself
learn something and grow wiser
don't blame other people for your
problems
workers work hard enough to not be fired
and business owners pay just enough so
that workers won't quit
without a strong reason or purpose
anything in life is hard
winners are not afraid of losing losers
are
failure is part of the process of
success
people who avoid failure miss success
if you want to be rich you need to
develop your vision
you must be standing on the edge of time
gazing into the future
[Music]
the fear of being different prevents
most people from seeking new ways to
solve their problems
don't be addicted to money
work to learn don't work for money work
for knowledge
[Music]
the trouble with school is they give you
the answer then they give you the exam
that's not life
[Music]
it's more important to grow your income
than to cut your expenses
it's more important to grow your spirit
than to cut your dreams
the most successful people in life are
the ones who ask questions
they're always learning they're always
growing they're always pushing
complaining about your current position
in life is worthless
have a spine to do something about it
instead
in the real world the smartest people
are those who make mistakes and learn
in school the smartest people don't make
mistakes
it's not what you say out of your mouth
that determines your life
it's what you whisper to yourself
it's easier to stand on the sidelines
criticize and say why you shouldn't do
something
the sidelines are crowded
get in the game
most people in their drive to get rich
are trying to build an empire state
building on a six-inch slab
[Music]
more money seldom solves someone's money
problems
the more we know about the power of
money the more distant we grow from our
teachers and our classmates
[Music]
an asset puts money in my pocket
a liability takes money out of my pocket
[Music]
a person can be highly educated
professionally successful and
financially illiterate
by not understanding money the vast
majority of people allow its awesome
power to control them
[Music]
an intelligent person hires people who
are more intelligent than he is
i'd rather welcome change than cling to
the past
the greater your financial intelligence
the easier it is to tell whether a deal
is good
if you're still doing what mommy and
daddy said for you to do
go to school get a job save money
you're losing
[Music]
you